i have some really interesting video to
go through with you guys today uh we are
going to look at an interview
that republican kentucky senator rand
paul
did yesterday on newsmax tv
with host greg kelly and he really makes
a complete fool of himself and there's
something very interesting happening
with rand paul
you might remember that rand paul kind
of became buddies with donald trump
while donald trump was president they
would play golf
and increasingly rand paul would defend
the things that donald trump would say
and do
and the the pattern tended to be trump
would say something completely wacky or
crazy
or suggest or enact some completely
hair-brained policy or executive order
and rand paul would then appear on tv
and he would sort of put like a slightly
less crazy spin on it compared to donald
trump
and compared to the way trump was
talking about the issue rand paul would
seem
marginally more rational but what's
going on now
is that with donald trump gone rand paul
is still saying
equivalently wacky things as to what he
was saying before
but without the even crazier trump to
compare him to
he seems as out of his mind as he has
been for many many years so let's take a
look
at some of these rand paul here says you
can't impeach a president who has left
office of course ignoring the fact that
donald trump was impeached while in
office
it's the trial that will start soon but
the impeachment of trump remember
impeachment happens in the house
did take place while donald trump was
president he had a vote on the floor
and 45 republicans said look you can't
really impeach somebody who's already
left office that doesn't make any sense
at all
so they've been repeating this one a lot
it's wrong trump
was impeached while president but
imagine
that defense anywhere else the murder
i committed yeah i did that when i was a
manager of a kfc
i don't have that job anymore so
anything i did while working
at that job doesn't count because i
can't get fired from there anymore i
already don't work there
what where else would that argument
apply and of course
it's factually wrong since trump was
impeached
while he was president of the united
states
then rand paul tries to both sides
the january 6th trump riots by saying
listen
remember when that guy shot steve
scalise
he was a bernie supporter incited by
health care now what incited by health
care means i don't know
but let's listen to rand paul listen to
beat this
and i think it's a terrible thing that
they're doing to the country
the other thing is is that even on the
facts of the matter whether or not there
was an incitement of violence
i also mentioned in that speech you
showed on the floor
that look when i was at the ball field
and steve scalise was almost killed
four other staffers were shot including
one of them that was 10 feet from me
the guy who shot shot up the ball field
and almost killed
20 of us was a bernie sanders supporter
and he had been incited by health care
incited by incited by health care
is not a phrase you typically hear in
the world
but of course rand paul here is either
being disingenuous
or ignorant bernie sanders didn't incite
anyone to shoot
anybody if the guy who shot steve
scalise
was a bernie supporter and he shot steve
scalise
that's very different than trump at 12
45 on january 6th
saying we're going down to the capitol
and rudy's saying
we're going to do trial by combat and on
and on and then at 1 15 pm 30 minutes
later they do it they do it because
trump said it and because they thought
they could steal the election for trump
the analogy
is so absurd it's not even coherent and
we're seeing this from more republicans
than just rand paul trying to sort of
both sides this
um to try to make what happened on
january 6th
equivalent to other things and of course
there's there's two layers in which
uh there's two ways in which it's not
equivalent number one
the acts that took place on january 6th
are dramatically different
than what these right-wingers are trying
to equate them to but more importantly
no president sitting or former incited
any of the other stuff
that they are talking about and that's
the subject matter of the impeachment
rand paul then goes on a very strange
rant
where he starts saying that a lot of
what
is called climate change might be merely
be the result of the earth's
tilt not greenhouse gases or human
activities on earth
scientists disagree with what rand paul
is saying here remember rand paul's an
ophthalmologist
well some of this started a while back
because you know when we started talking
about climate change and global warming
that was before they decided they
weren't sure whether it was getting
colder or warmer but now it's climate
change
it's become so sort of settled science
that everybody says there's only one way
you can think
that that's a recipe for a
close-mindedness that
really prevents innovation and prevents
us moving forward
but if i were to say that there's
geological
changes over long periods of time about
a hundred thousand year cycles
these were called the milosevic cycles
and that they have to do with hot and
cold and i'm not sure
how much is sort of this natural
phenomenon based on the earth's tilt
and how much is true to man they would
say i'm a denier
so it's it's not that rand paul
is a denier per se although
it sounds like he might be it's that
he's an ideologically
biased libertarian ophthalmologist
who doesn't know about this stuff and
for political reasons doesn't want to
accept what science
has determined to be the reality on this
issue
so what's very instructive for me about
this is that
for some of us compared to the wackiness
of trump
a lot of these other republicans for the
last four years
start you know up to a week ago a lot of
these republicans for the last four
years
seemed comparatively less crazy than
donald trump and
it's probably true to some degree with
trump now gone
we are reminded of just how wacky
rand paul is and just how wacky a lot of
these other people are
we knew it all along but with trump in
comparison
it was less obvious in some ways it's
now
very very clear one of our sponsors
today
is lucy and they are giving my audience
20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical